Trascrizione: Monike Erika Alves
Revisore: Piero Cavallo
Le donne sono più sensibili degli uomini.
Infatti gli uomini non piangono.
Ma che “zabetta” che sei,
peggio di un uomo, peggio di una donna.
Donna al volante, pericolo costante.
Qualcuno, magari, sentendo
queste frasi potrebbe pensare:
“Ma sì, ma sono solo parole,
si sono sempre dette.”
“Dei modi di dire,
non è mai morto nessuno.”
Ma siamo sicuri che le parole
siano così innocue?
Perché le parole hanno un forte impatto,
molto più di quanto noi
possiamo immaginare.
Noi, tramite le parole, descriviamo
e diamo forma ai nostri pensieri,
ma anche a tutto ciò che ci circonda.
È tramite le parole che
noi lo descriviamo.
E una cosa che molte persone
molto spesso non notano è
quanto il linguaggio che noi utilizziamo
tutti i giorni sia altamente stereotipato.
Il problema rappresentato
dagli stereotipi,
nel mio caso, come forse avrete notato,
mi soffermerò su quelli di genere,
è il fatto che possono portare anche
a delle discriminazioni più o meno gravi.
Ogni volta, quando parliamo, noi,
senza molte volte rendercene conto,
portiamo una serie di stereotipi,
di luoghi comuni,
che portano avanti anche
moltissimi pregiudizi
e possono anche conseguire,
oltre alle discriminazioni,
alle persone che sono oggetto
di tali aggressioni stereotipiche,
al sentirsi sbagliate, inadeguate,
o addirittura alcune persone potrebbero
persino iniziare a provare un fastidio
verso loro stesse per non soddisfare
queste aspettative sociali
date dagli stereotipi.
E, se non da loro stesse, per gli altri
potrebbero iniziare a provare
una sorta di irritazione, di fastidio.
“Sei donna, non puoi stare qui.”
Bufera sulla Nazionale Cantanti.
Cosa è successo?
Aurora Leone dei The Jackal è stata
cacciata da una partita di beneficenza
a cui era stata invitata perché, in quanto
donna, non poteva giocare a calcio.
Questa è stata proprio
la motivazione specifica.
Mentre, invece, dall’altra parte abbiamo
un altro caso totalmente differente.
Chef si commuove in tv, Carlo Cracco:
“Non piangere, sei un uomo!”
Ora, non pensiamo solamente
a queste due notizie.
Cerchiamo di guardare oltre,
sulle conseguenze.
Pensiamo alla prima notizia:
una ragazzina appassionata di sport,
con magari una particolare
curiosità per il calcio,
leggendo qualcosa del genere,
potrebbe pensare:
“No, ma perché perdo tempo?
Tanto essendo donna non mi
faranno mai giocare.”
Magari al primo errore diranno:
“Eh ma è ovvio,
sei una donna non sai giocare.”
Appelleranno l’errore sul fatto che
appartenga al genere femminile.
Magari questo potrebbe anche
farle passare la voglia,
perché pensare di entrare in un mondo
pieno di discriminazioni
potrebbe farla desistere dall’entrare,
per dire, ad esempio in un team calcistico
anche se potrebbe desiderare tutto ciò.
Ma passiamo anche, per dire, non solo
alla dimensione calcistica, ma anche,
per esempio, se pensiamo ai lavori che
stereotipicamente associamo al maschile
come, ad esempio,
l’idraulico o il meccanico,
magari una ragazza penserà...
Infatti, mi ricollego qui a
una frase sentita dire una volta:
“Figurati se una ragazza
scende a cambiare le gomme.”
Sentire una cosa del genere farà
pensare a una ragazza:
“Ma perché perdo tempo
a imparare sta roba
se tanto ci sarà un uomo
che lo farà al posto mio?
A me che cosa mi servirà mai nella vita?”
E pensiamo, invece, all’altro esempio.
Immaginiamo un ragazzo, un bambino,
leggere o sentire una cosa del genere
leggere che gli uomini non piangono
perché sono uomini,
Perché gli uomini non piangono,
questa è un’azione più da femminucce.
E non ho utilizzato questo epiteto a caso,
perché questo epiteto fortemente
sessista ha due doppi significati:
fa pensare che l’emotività sia una
caratteristica prettamente femminile.
Uno stereotipo sostanzialmente.
E soprattutto fa in modo che
un uomo si senta offeso
all’essere paragonato a una donna.
Quindi ha anche una valenza
sessista piuttosto grave.
Perché, appunto, gli stereotipi alla fine,
oltre alle discriminazioni, come ho detto,
possono anche fare in modo che una persona
se non rientra in questi stereotipi,
come la ragazzina amante del calcio
o dei lavori “considerati maschili”,
potrebbe sentirsi a disagio, un pesce fuor
d’acqua, per non rientrare nella massa.
Un ragazzo potrebbe pensare che, per non
vedere il suo essere uomo invalidato,
debba reprimere le proprie emozioni,
non debba piangere,
perché altrimenti verrà discriminato.
Come è successo a questo concorrente
redarguito per aver meramente
espresso delle emozioni.
Ma anche qui estendiamo, per esempio.
la questione anche ai lavori domestici
ai lavori di cura che solitamente
qui vengono associati,
sempre stereotipicamente,
alle donne.
Allora questo ragazzo penserà:
“Ma perché io faccio ste cose?
Tanto le fanno le donne, io sono uomo.”
E, quindi, qui vediamo che le parole
si stanno trasformando in dei fatti.
Il problema principale degli stereotipi
è che molte volte sono così
normalizzati nel nostro linguaggio che
magari neanche ce ne rendiamo conto
di star attuando una discriminazione
sessista perché sono proprio normalizzati.
E in certi casi, addirittura, pensiamo
persino di fare un complimento.
Quindi noi attuiamo
delle aggressioni sessiste
con l’intenzione di fare dei complimenti.
E qui, per esempio: “La vera cucina
rimane quella delle donne.
Cucinano per nutrire, hanno
l’ospitalità nel DNA,
nessuno chef uomo potrà
mai fare altrettanto.”
E qui vi chiedo ma questo
è un complimento o è un’offesa?
Qual era l'intento di Bastianich?
Allora, ovviamente Bastianich
in questo caso stava cercando di fare
un complimento alle chef, perché
si ritrovano in un mondo molto maschilista
come quello della cucina,
che purtroppo non è il solo,
e, quindi, per dimostrare che comunque
loro non valgono da meno,
ha deciso di utilizzare questa frase,
cadendo però, purtroppo, senza volerlo,
nello stereotipo sessista
secondo cui le donne in cucina
hanno una marcia in più perché
in quanto donne abituate a cucinare
per amore, accudire i propri cari...
Insomma, un uomo non potrà mai competere
perché non ha questa sorta
di accudimento nel DNA.
Ovviamente, l’intenzione di Bastianich
si limitava al complimento.
Non aveva intenzione di riportare
avanti questi stereotipi datati.
E per proprio questo dico che
certe volte le parole che utilizziamo
hanno un impatto che nemmeno
noi realizziamo che abbiano,
perché, appunto, per fare un complimento
magari riportiamo in auge degli stereotipi
e qualcuno magari potrebbe pensare:
“Ma io quindi che cosa posso fare
se voglio complimentare qualcuno?”
Riprendiamo sempre questo caso,
un’alternativa non stereotipata
sarebbe potuta essere ad esempio:
“Purtroppo ancora oggi il mondo della
cucina è fortemente maschilista,
però io conosco moltissime chef che
non hanno nulla da invidiare
ai loro colleghi uomini”, per esempio.
E adesso, allora, vi starete
chiedendo perché ho deciso
di portare sul palco
questo argomento?
Ecco, ho deciso di portare questo
argomento proprio perché
i cambiamenti maggiori alla fine
passano dal nostro linguaggio.
È tramite le parole che diciamo che diamo
una forma al mondo che ci circonda.
E quindi se iniziassimo a utilizzare
una comunicazione più inclusiva,
meno stereotipata,
proprio libera dagli stereotipi,
potremmo fare in modo di eliminare
piano piano le discriminazioni,
prima da un punto di vista linguistico,
ma poi anche da un punto
di vista quotidiano, concreto.
E fare in modo che le persone non
si sentano più sbagliate o discriminate
per appartenere a un determinato genere,
possano essere libere
di essere loro stesse senza pensare
che l’aspettativa di genere
a loro dice qualcos’altro.
E quindi quando parliamo dovremmo
focalizzarci sulla persona
e non sul genere.
Dovremmo fare una cosa.
Dovremmo andare oltre il genere.
(Applausi)